RFK Jr I had him on the show a couple
days ago and we talked about conspiracy
theories and slow motion reality and
time release truth and all that stuff I
asked people to come up with some of
your dangerous ideas and nobody seems to
really know what they are but that
doesn't stop the New York Times yeah and
all of my conspiracy theories as it
turns out have come true they're no
longer theories they're you know they're
now proven hypotheses but I do wonder
about it I you know I was thinking about
this this morning because the the this
kind of this hail storm of negative
publicity about I mean really kind of
not it goes beyond like hit pieces it's
to be just is you know poisonous vitriol
that it's coming from all the Legacy
Media from the Atlantic Monthly from New
York Magazine New York or the Washington
Post and the New York Times from Vanity
Fair and they all kind of use the same
talking points and uh and they also are
not accurate and that's one of the
reasons it doesn't trouble me is because
it's it's just it's just inaccuracies
distortions
Brian it seems like uh he's just getting
a dose of what Republicans have been
getting a dose of for a long time
yeah so here's what's so fascinating to
me about this you know we talked earlier
about how Trump didn't show up because
at some level he didn't want to punch
down he's so far ahead Biden and his
team and frankly those around him that
they're punching as it were down they're
trying to take this guy out even though
he is dramatically behind in the polls
if you believe most of them but the so
the point is they they actually view him
as a threat there's something about him
that is very frightening to the Democrat
Party so that to me I think is perhaps
the most interesting of development over
the past week or so which is this guy is
resonating at some level that scares a
living crap out of the Biden campaign
and other Democrats to me there's
something else going on here that he's
tapping into and I think that that's
really important to acknowledge Michael
you debate Democrats all the time and go
to college events where you often open
up the floor I do it too I always say if
you disagree with me you come up first
you you do that stuff all the time I
know it's getting harder and harder to
find sort of legit people to debate with
the fact that this guy is obviously not
going to be allowed on the stage with
Biden they're never going to have him
Primary in the first place that's one
thing but further in the conversation I
said to him are you in any contact with
the Democratic party the DNC no that was
the answer one word no does that tell
you all you need to know about the
Democrats the Republicans for all their
faults when Trump was the Renegade in
they didn't stop him he ran right
through and took over the Democrats are
full on stopping the Renegade and by the
way they've done this before cue Bernie
Sanders and think about who the Renegade
is the Renegade is Affinity is Jack
Kennedy's nephew Bobby Kennedy's son
he's in his own right a major figure on
the left for the past 30 40 years now
but because he contradicts their
narrative on a few issues and more
importantly because he threatens their
power now the guy's totally out forget
about what the DNC is saying about him
and Biden look at what his own sister
says about him Bobby Kennedy is filmed
at a dinner
mentioning a scientific theory what does
he say he says there's a a fear now that
there are ethnically targeted bio
weapons which is just true that's been
written about in magazines for years and
he says and there is a theory about
kovid that it's harsher on certain races
than it is on other races
also true you can look up the scientific
paper all the man is saying is there is
a theory which you can read in a
scientific paper that's published a
couple years ago that this this has
different effects with different genetic
backgrounds is called an anti-semite a
vile racist by not only the White House
his own sister sister Carrie Kennedy it
reminds you that on the Democrat side on
the left broadly
there is no more important tie than
political convenience and that includes
immediate family